here
hey yes this is andrew for
twinsenses.com so we are live again from
panama we're gonna go today through the
price action price action on amc on gme
we have some very big moves happening we
have a lot a lot of volume so let's see
everything that can happen we're going
to discuss targets we're going to
discuss potential pullbacks what levels
can be bought can we still uh get in uh
in amc or jamie at good levels or is it
too late uh we're gonna discuss all of
that so let's start right now with amc
so
uh i'm on a daily timeframe guys and
like i've said yesterday um
we are still to me in a first impulse
that is the beginning of something big
so
we had the biggest volume yesterday
traded
226 million shares the biggest volume
since august 24th guys
uh so
this is starting to be really hot we're
gonna have a look of course at the short
interest uh let's try to see if shorts
are covering or not um
so first let's
see what happened yesterday we moved up
by 45 percent the pre-market is
up today uh amc is about to open at 30.4
guys so we are moving higher uh the
interesting thing i have here if i go on
the hourly time frame guys you can see
that we had a massive volume at the open
all right this is the open
when we went through this 22 level that
was the last resistance we had
and then we arrived on the 26th level i
was live with you guys we were analyzing
that and as you can see we had the first
rejection and it took amc
one two three four hours to go through
this level and look at the volume like i
said guys so when we have some strong
resistance levels
we always need it means that there are a
lot of sellers waiting there and
if we want to go through this um
all these selling orders
we need a lot of volume and here
it was like in the middle of the day at
the end of the day we had this huge
increase in volume let me zoom in even a
little bit more guys
we have this volume look guys
the volume was just increasing and
non-stop until the close so buyers are
really coming back
and and they are strong and it's the
first time we can see this volume like
that during the day as you can see
usually we are we were starting with a
huge volume then decreasing and then of
course you have a little increase of the
volume at the close but here guys we had
not a little increase of the volume of
the close we had a massive increase of
volume at the close which means once
again that there are a lot of players
that were not in the amc trade anymore
that would that were waiting for uh some
signals to get in that start to buy so
let's see what we can do today but first
we went through this 26 resistance level
so right now 26 is a support if today
the press action comes back to 26 i
don't think it can happen but if it
comes back to 26 26 is a good level to
buy i would personally be buying some
shares at this level
um
what else can i tell you
two minutes to open uh yeah so i don't
see any reason the next resistance level
this is what we're interested in the
next resistance level is right now uh 32
33 it's not easy once again to be very
precise yesterday guys i gave you 26. it
was not very useful because we are not
targeting to sell some shares but um i'm
going to try of course to do the same
with support level whenever the press
action will start to weaken i'm gonna be
monitoring with you guys during the day
if this press action is weakening but i
can already tell you that for now it is
not the case at all so the next
resistance level like i said is 32 33
why 32 33 32 i get this level just as
usual by placing my trend lines where i
had the previous reactions previous
highs previous lows previous
considerations and i pay a lot i pay
attention a lot to the volume traded
when i whenever i have a lot of volume
that was exchanged at the level
i considered this level like a fair
level where there are a lot of buyers
and sellers that traded there a long
time ago and that that consider oh i
sold here uh or i bought here six months
ago it's a good level to sell or i sold
here a few months away so it's a good
level to buy back this kind of reasoning
apply whenever you have a lot of volume
that has been traded at a level this is
the reason why i pay attention to the
volume and like i said previous highs
probably slows so
here as you can see it's just the recent
high okay uh i i once again i don't use
the closing level i use the highs
because i consider that this
is where the rejection occurred
and 32 is level that was traded on um
deck 21st okay
then i also have the uh 200-day moving
average that as you guys know is a very
important indicator that is followed by
a lot of asset managers and hedge funds
and you know all these guys that uh you
know do some technical analysis uh to
um enter the trades they don't usually
take the view based on technical
analysis they're gonna take the view
based on the flows like volume so
volumes technical analysis but you know
it should be it's a little bit different
uh style of technical analysis but they
keep an eye on this 200-day moving
average and i know that because i have
some friends that work for some asset
managers and they're telling me that yes
of course they pay attention to this
level all right so this is the reason
why this is my next resistance
and we are we are right now in the
middle of 26 which is support and 32 33
so let's see what we can do today uh i
think that 32 33 will be hit
so it's a nine percent move up so not
that big the question is can we go
beyond that level today and the answer
is of course yes everything is possible
we are in a situation that we've never
been uh for quite some time i don't even
know if we if we have ever been in this
situation i think this is what is
happening right now is kind of unique
okay you see amc is just moving strongly
higher guys bam i don't see the time gme
little bit low lower amc up so you see
the spread we're gonna have a look at
the uh premium that jimmy was trading
at
two days ago i mean on friday and today
i can already tell you guys that this
premium
has vanished i can see right away amc up
five percent to gme down two or three
percent uh so it's it's okay now they
are both at levels where
um
[Music]
at fair levels one compared to the other
so uh amc papa going almost to the level
so let's see what's gonna happen here
once again uh if we go there at the open
at the open you guys know that we have a
lot of volume and we need a lot of
volume to go through this level so let's
see if we're able to do it if we are
able to do it to do it the next
resistance would be
around 44 45 okay we have a little one
at 36.
uh let me place it so just we you know
mark the level but it's it's it's a weak
one i'm gonna put it with a light trend
line okay
okay
to d4
i'm placing it yes give me a sec
trying to place it as good as i can
so this is 35
okay i don't see very clearly between 22
33 and 44. what i know is that the next
big one is 44. okay
so maybe we can go to to this level
uh this week maybe even today guys let's
see if we have the same kind of
performance as we did yesterday we are
already trading at 2d2 guys
gme moving higher as well uh so i'm
gonna do a full analysis on jamie uh
very soon so the question we're having
is um
[Music]
is there gonna be any pullback in this
uh in this move up so i was saying
yesterday that we're waiting for a
second wave pullback uh we still do uh
but let me you know just
say something more today is that this
massive move that we had 44 percent uh
when i finished my lab i think we were
up 30
so and the volume increased a lot so
this is changing a little bit things um
[Music]
i think the pullbacks will be very quick
very shallow and both uh very quickly so
i don't know if you're gonna have the
same kind of pullback we did
here for example this was a four days
pullback but the difference between here
and what we're having right now is that
we didn't move with such a volume uh and
did a move of 40 45 move up so right now
um
let's see let's see what's gonna happen
uh it's very possible that we just keep
keep going higher shorts are under
pressure we just uh reached the 33 level
let's see what's gonna happen here guys
i'm live review right now i'm gonna go
in the 15 minutes time frame
where is my volume
okay
so
guys we're going through it okay the
volume is here so let's analyze right
away this volume as you can see the
volume is already bigger than the volume
we had yesterday at the open and we have
we are only training for five minutes
guys so uh amc is already up 15
yes this is happening we're going
through this level
okay papa
so let's see it seems to me right now
look that guy's there there is no fight
here it's only one way i don't see even
best trying to you know
do something
bulls are extremely strong in full
control
we're gonna come back to that in one
minute let me go on gme guys because uh
some of you were asking me to make the
usual updates amc gme so today maybe i'm
gonna do a little bit shorter live and
um and i'm gonna do the usual you know
15 minutes updates where i try to give
you the maximum of information um
maybe i will also do
tomorrow
uh full updates instead of a live i
don't know so let me know guys if you
have something that you prefer uh but i
kind of feel that those videos are you
know easier for some viewers to get the
information instead of going through the
live so let's see but for now today i'm
live guys with you so uh jimmy let's do
some technical analysis bam bam bam
daily time frame
so
i'm here using a regular scale
oh right so we went through this 160
level guys
in a very you know strong
way once again with volume without any
you know pullbacks anything it's just
pure strength uh so we even went through
the 180 level that was not as strong as
the 160 but you can see that the
resistances even if they you know should
give a little uh
of a little bit of rejection they are
just breaking right away so this is a
very very good sign of strengths it
means that buyers are just you know um
they don't give any chance to sell us
and we went through the 180 level
uh which is now support
papa
okay i can see him see for now rejected
a little bit so we're gonna have a look
at that uh 180 is support on gme um once
again the volume is very very strong
guys so i think we're gonna move uh we
can go to 250 today it's possible
um
it's possible
so
let's so yeah i wanted to show you guys
that the 180 level is right now support
we can try once again to use moving
averages uh to find some other support
levels
but um that'll be far from now uh the
movie is already a bit extended which
just doesn't mean that it won't extend
more it just means that moving averages
uh the usual moving averages that can
give some support are quite far so uh i
don't know if we're gonna dip today but
i can see we're dipping a little bit but
if we dip
we can then use those moving averages to
um to find some support levels so uh let
me do the
usual analysis on gme for those who want
to see that one so we broke out above
160 with volume we closed even above 180
180 is now support we are developing in
five waves up so we are still in this
fifth wave uh of i think only the first
move up so this is the question i'm
having and i'm gonna be very honest with
you guys i have absolutely uh no
guarantee no uh clue i mean i have some
hints about how this up can happen but
things can be different from one time to
the other time because i'm just trying
to analyze what happened in the past
but you know the situation each time is
different because we have different
players they have different information
sellers are prepared but i don't know
how they are prepared buyers are
prepared as well and i don't know
exactly what what what is happening who
is doing what but i can see that uh you
know some big money players know exactly
what they do and you know they have
control of what is happening this is
very obvious and for now bulls are in
full full control um
so
what i mean is that we can very well you
know i'm trying to give you a scenario
where we're gonna move up then pull back
and go up again um i'm wondering if
you know given once again the very
strong moves that we see and the total
um
[Music]
you know the fact that the bears are
really not uh trying to do anything i'm
wondering if this pullbacks won't happen
uh at higher levels we of course gonna
have them because you're gonna have some
profit taking because once again the
bulls that are buying today that both
jimmy 120 both at 130 uh 160 where we
had a lot of volume those guys uh
they're you know probably big money
players they're gonna be taking profits
at some point and whenever they're gonna
be taking profits we're gonna see this
pullback but the question is where is it
going to happen um and once again we can
look at the past even for example here
you know
in every move we have those pullbacks
but sometimes they happen much higher
than where the initial volume started
so uh to me
i have two scenarios
uh
so my first scenario is that the fifth
wave
is almost complete but i don't really
believe in that because once again
yesterday's move was so strong that i
think we need a little bit more than
that uh we're gonna monitor on the
shorter timeframe once again what is the
volume doing and what is the momentum
doing this is going to give us
information um the second scenario is
that we go right away to 250 and then
if we do that i think that we would need
at some point to see a pullback so it is
too early to really discuss the levels
where we could pull back uh but usually
we pull back to the 38.2 percent if in
those strong moves up uh we put back to
the 38.2 percent so if we go to 250 it
would be 185. if we go lower i can
already give you the levels
uh if we go only to 200 where we went
briefly this morning 199
the 38.2 is 155 so then once we have
those areas we need to use the usual
support levels that we have so moving
averages trend lines and try to know
where bulls are located okay so we're
going to do that together whenever we
see some pullbacks for now uh we
you know we moved
higher now a little bit lower let's see
uh we're gonna monitor the volume i'm
gonna go on shorter timeframe very soon
guys
amc altered really
i see your comments
yeah true guys
[Music]
what is happening so let's let let me
try to find some news let me know guys
if you know exactly
what happens
okay i'm trying to find news with you
live
okay indeed 9 38 so three minutes ago
amc entertainment trading halted
volatility training pose
you know the starting
the starting so
um
the story was produced by the fly blah
blah blah to learn more
okay let's try to find more information
about that
okay i don't see for now more
information
i'm surprised because we dipped
just before it was halted
that's weird
i was i would like rather expect we move
strongly higher and it's halted to
protect the shorts but here i mean
if if it drops a little bit more it's
pretty good because we can buy some
shares right so
um
and it's good for shots as well they can
buy back lower
i don't know what they held right now
halted because it dropped from 34 to 21
in one minute i don't know
it's a volatility uh issue apparently
the question i'm having is why did they
do that
okay it's opening again i don't know if
it's live
prices
let me try let me see if i can try to do
something here
okay it's it seems working
let me place those hundred shares and 26
26
0.9
okay
ah okay
okay guys but it seems that uh it's back
i think my order was placed um
i hope so
my trade station crashed actually
but i see the price moving you guys
telling me that
it's coming back so it seems things are
back to normal it was a very very short
halt but we can see that things start to
be hot let's have a look guys at the
option market
let me just reconnect
to my train station
okay
okay my shows are placed that's good
cool
bam um
okay
so many things i want to show you guys
we can quickly have a look at the global
market as well
uh as you have probably heard we uh we
have finally some good news coming from
the russia ukraine conflict the good
news is naturally news is just uh that
vladimir putin accepted to meet in
person i mean not really accepted but
he's open to maybe meet in person
vladimir zelinski which is the first
time we hear that from um the russian
government so of course this is good
news uh the reason behind is that you
know he cannot really uh do what he
wanted to do in ukraine he will it would
be very hard for him to uh change the uh
current government and to put some of
his friends you know to control the
country as the ukraine resistance is
extremely strong
um
so he agrees to maybe um
accept a deal from ukraine and this is
of course very positive regarding the
war that might maybe end uh if things go
well but for now this is not happening
but markets enjoyed this information and
uh we are arrived and this is when
technical analysis is useful yes because
we have a news
we have a gap up
we
and we can see that we arrived exactly
sorry guys i have some
things
what is that
okay
and we can see that we arrived right on
a resistance
317
so i was discussing this scenario with
you yesterday i said that my preferred
scenario on triple two is that we go
there i was saying on low volatility it
is not on low volatility we we went
there uh with yesterday plus 1.5 and
today uh a gap up of plus 1.3 so
this are not extremely strong moves but
it's not exactly the scenario i was
imagining i was rather uh thinking of
something where we just grind up slowly
uh here we went a little bit quick to me
so whenever anything is quick uh usually
it's not stable all right i prefer to
see plus zero five plus one plus zero
seven minus zero five you know this kind
of move that is healthy that is usually
the kind of moves we see whenever we
have a bull market
rather than seeing
uh um you know those strong moves so
let's see um if we have volume and are
able to close above this 370 level today
this would be very good news regarding
uh the the sentiment on the global
market so let's see if we're able to do
that
for now we just arrived on this
resistance i personally sold a little
bit of triple q here i sold a cold
spread so um basically if nothing
happens i make money and if we go higher
i will lose but a little bit uh and if
we drop i win a little bit it's it's a
small position i just want to
to lock in some profits i have on shares
that have both uh on the global market
not amc and gme i'm talking here so
let's see let's see if we have a dip i
will buy back personally at 350. okay so
this is a different story for gme and
amc
because anything pretty much can happen
here and amc and gme can move strongly
higher even if we have a dip here but on
triple q i had some questions about that
yesterday once again my view is that we
consolidate here and at some point we
take a direction okay so i think that
we're gonna move sideways for the coming
uh one or even two months between 350
and 370. so it's a tight range so that's
why i expect the volatility to drop
let's have a look today at the vegs guys
and once again this is important if we
enter a bear market of course it's not
going to be easy for stocks like amc and
jimmy to squeeze so it's important for
triple q just that we stay above 350. i
don't know what's going to happen this
week i don't know what's going to happen
next week but um i know that if we go
below 350 um fear is going to come back
so we don't want the fear to come back
we want everybody that can buy shells to
feel good to feel in a safe environment
to trade all right this is what we need
so we don't need a strong massive rally
it's not useful as well um maybe it's a
little bit better but a sideways market
is perfect so that amc and jme can do
that thing okay
uh all right so what else i wanted to
show you guys
so triple q i gave you my view yes i
want you to check the vix once again the
vix so what do you expect i expect the
vix today to be lower
why because
the fear should slightly slowly go
whenever we have good news about a
potential end of the conflict so let's
see yesterday the vix was turning at
20.5 i expect the biggs to be at 19.5
today
19.3 okay so guys i told you about that
event before i told you that probably
we're gonna have triple two
at 370 and uh spy let's let's quickly
check sp y guys
and then i'm go i'm gonna get back to
mcgm i'm keeping an eye on it don't
worry guys it's right now 29 180. so amc
flat jamie losing five percent we're
gonna come back to it we're gonna
discuss targets today it's still early
but let's discuss targets guys we're
going to adjust those targets if needed
but we can already have some information
we can try to project the move that
happened before to get some potential
levels where uh buyers would take
profits i'm talking here about buyers
like asset managers and those guys
because
they will take profit at some point
okay so spy guys very strong
spy bam bam bam what is
okay so you see i'm having mixed signals
because spy is trading above 457
so
i can just a little bit my level but
let's be honest it's 457 so this is
really good news uh you can see it's
happening for now on very low volume but
it's pretty normal because the day has
just started so let's see if we can have
this breakout with volume once again the
breakout without volume is not a very
reliable breakout uh so we're gonna
monitor that as well but this is rather
good news then my level uh of resistance
on spy was rather i mean it was an area
clearly starting at 447
but the breakout level is at 460. so
let's see maybe we have a little bit of
excess and maybe we're just breaking out
above this level once again for a
breakout to be good quality we need to
have volume this is the reason why we
are checking the volume um
we are always checking the volume
okay
so uh that that that that uh
so yeah it's a lot of comments today
thank you very much for watching hit the
like button guys we're gonna stay
together uh today watching the price
action of amc and jimmy trying to find
guys where we have potential support
levels resistance levels so as you can
see the 32 33 level guys it was very
messy what happened there there was a
halt uh that happened at um
eight minutes after the open if i am
correct
uh let's check on the one minute time
frame exactly what we had
okay the alt was the halt was here we
can clearly see the volume
uh
so we had the rejection before the halt
okay and the health
happened here
i don't know exactly how this processes
you know happen i know that
i was trading once again uh the indices
when i was uh in banking and i know that
you know they have some rules for
example on the snp 500 uh i think there
is a halt whenever the snp futures move
more than seven percent something like
that i'm not exactly sure each in index
has its own rule but i was not so i
think that on amc
i don't know we can try to find this
information uh but here definitely there
was no not any strong move so
it's a volatility reason
but come on
what was that move
okay we m we dropped by seven percent in
one minute
and this created the halt
so i don't know maybe there is a rule
like you cannot move more than
five percent in one minute this is what
you guys were telling me so halted
because it dropped from 34 to 29
in one minute
24 to 29.
i took three minutes bro from 34 to 29
but it dropped from 31
to 20 sorry from 31 to 29
in one minute this is the biggest
one-minute move i'm seeing
i cannot go on a shorter time frame
because maybe this one minute candle is
not you know not really starting here
and finishing here so we would need to
go to the 30 second time frame i don't
have that time frame here
but for the first time maybe it would
have been uh
useful i think it was 10 in x minute
okay interesting
interesting but i don't understand this
never happened before
i mean this since
we started to move that's strongly
higher
okay fair enough it was the biggest one
okay
okay
and then
okay
interesting but you we can see that the
volume
uh dropped okay
but it's still quite substantial
let's compare to yesterday's volume guys
i like to see the volume bigger and
bigger like we said let's go back on a
daily timeframe
we still have some room guys
we can check you know
we know what amc is capable of because
this kind of moves happened in the past
and amc is capable of trading 700
million shares in one day so basically
three times more than that okay
so it's pretty interesting
okay
okay guys so uh pam pam pam what else
can we check
vic's
emc yeah so let's discuss targets we're
gonna check the short interest let's
check uh the short interest right now or
you prefer to discuss targets
um the short interest i i mean it's
always interesting to have a look at it
but you know the updates occur after
some time so we can always analyze the
difference between today and yesterday
um but it's just it's a slow process so
let's discuss targets i think it's more
exciting
so
okay we don't have that many tools we
can use to find targets
so um we're going to use what we have we
have fib projections
we have trend lines
we have
that's pretty much it guys we have trend
lines and a few projections
but we can apply field projections on
different um
on different time frames so first let's
do the basic
uh fib projection
target you guys know what i'm talking
about all right i'm gonna even go in the
weekly time frame we're gonna do that
we're gonna project last move up
two
last week okay
so
it's pretty easy to do you guys can do
the same if you want
once again i've been doing that for a
long time it gives you area okay there
is nothing very precise in this
uh but whenever you don't have any other
tool
what happens is that other people do the
same thing as you and
as this is i think the most common
method to find targets using those
protections
it happens actually quite often that the
levels the ratios the common ratios are
actually acting as resistance which
doesn't mean that we cannot go above it
just means that you know it it helps you
to know where the sellers
in this case profit takers or maybe even
shorts that want to add
would be located so it gives you areas
where potentially uh you're gonna have
some rejections
so let's do that right now
okay i just want to see the chart
clearly so i will remove the drawings
just to do the exercise so that you guys
can see well what i'm doing
um so we find the
last we want to project the last move up
so we're gonna measure the last move up
so first
we can measure we can check if those
targets were working well in the past
okay
so here i'm just measuring the first
move up i'm applying to the bottom of
this second wave and i'm checking the
very high the um
the high the highest level we had in
june 21 was going to do 3.618
fib protection and as you can see we had
some reaction clearly at 35 i don't know
if you guys remember but i was there at
that time and i was saying that amc will
go to 35 when we were trading around
five
and to know that i was exactly using
what i've just done here i measured the
first move up that i had already i
applied to the bottom of the second
move down
and
i used the 1.618 and as you can see we
went there
we had a rejection
and then we moved to the 3.618 okay so
the first
information i get by doing that is that
fib projections
uh ratio
ratios give you some levels where you
have resistance okay
now i'm gonna do the same thing guys but
applied to the entire move up why am i
doing that because as you can see the
situation is totally different between
this move up
and you know this pullback and this
second move up that was you know
following
this first move up so this is the reason
why you measure the first you play to
the bottom of the second but here as you
can see guys the move up we need to
measure
is the entire move up because the
correction is the correction of this
entire move up not only the second one
or the first one so we do that and we
apply to the bottom of the
uh
second wave okay i was saying that i
would wait for
uh positive information on the
market on the press action to start
discuss target again and i do that guys
and i will just give you the levels i'm
seeing and we can discuss what levels
might be reached
um
so
the first
the most common one is the 1.618 so let
me put something here
the 1.618 is
but i'm gonna get i'm gonna need okay
okay so i'm giving you the levels here
then i go back to my previous charting
with all my trend lines because i need
them so 1.600 guys goes to 127.
one second okay 127
which is the very close to the targets i
used to have back in the uh back in june
when i was saying 135 so this area is
still um to me a major resistance area
once again doesn't mean we can go above
that but as you guys can see
you know this market is manipulated so
let's see what can happen uh but if we
have a proper short squeeze 130 will be
reached uh it's almost a short now the
next one is 198
which is the 2.618 and the 3.618 is 270.
why am i talking about the 3.618 because
i've just measured
the first wave here and i saw that the
second one went uh first to the 1.618
pullback and to the 3.618 so i think
uh it's interesting to
you know just
talk about those levels because this is
what happened in the past so you know
the past likes to reproduce itself so
here the levels would be 130 if we have
a small squeeze and if you have a strong
squeeze at 270. can it go above of
course it can
but it's not what i call a reasonable
target uh here the targets i'm giving
you guys between 130 and 270 are
reasonable targets uh but let's be
honest the 270 level as you guys can see
if it trades it's gonna trade for uh
only a few minutes okay it's not gonna
be a level that is gonna hold it's not
gonna be a level where you know you're
gonna have a normal training environment
with buyers and sellers you're only
gonna have probably uh
shorts that i tried to buy and i'm not
even sure
you know the retail investors or other
market participants would be allowed to
you know place orders so i think it's
going to be very wide and very
unpredictable
but those areas are
to me
making sense
okay guys so
hola
pam pam pam
i'm sorry we have some um cleaning
happening today i hope the noise is not
too strong for you guys i'm gonna keep
doing uh the updates
uh bam bam bam
so let me go back to my charging i'm
gonna do the same thing for jme
oh right so as we can see for now we got
let me quickly update you guys on what
is happening right now with amc
so we have this negative beta at play
again which is not bad to me uh we have
you know we reached the 32 level so okay
right now we can use fibs guys because
we have the two we have maybe what is uh
the top of the first wave okay uh
yesterday i was saying that maybe it's
26 uh we went through 26 just on my
level right now uh in my yesterday's amc
recap i was saying that 3233 might be
the um the top of the first wave
i don't know it makes sense to me for
different reasons uh you guys saw what
i've just done right with the targets
that i gave you for the long term i can
do the same for the short term
and i've done that of course before and
sorry and this is the reason why i i
think that 32 33
is a level that makes sense because if
you measure
one plus three you applied to the bottom
of the fourth wave
the 1.618 is at 33.8 okay
so and you all
also had the 200-day moving average and
you had
different um
different
other
and you had yeah the natural resistance
level so
maybe the first wave is complete maybe
not
okay but for now
uh we are seeing a red candle it would
be the first red candle
if we close it here
what can very well happen is that we
bounce from 26
and that we go again two to the
uh 233 today so i measure this okay and
as you can see the 38.2
retracement ratio is at 26.1
it is also where i had my um
resistance yesterday that is today's
support
so this is the reason why i placed an
order here uh if it gets lower it's good
news i can buy more
but i think that this first support
level is a level where buyers are
located okay uh i don't know if you guys
are buying today or not not financial
advice and i'm not telling you what to
do of course
but um
but i think that those who buy today
consider 26 as a good level so let's see
uh this is the case for me
um
once again let's then go on the shorter
time frame and try to see what is
happening with volume and momentum
first i want to have a look at jimmy so
gme guys
so same thing we happened higher we're
getting rejected so we can already start
to so i don't know if this first wave
can go to 250 i think it's a um very
possible scenario
uh for now we're having for the first
time is a rejection okay it's the first
time we see this kind of candle since
this move up has started so is it a
second wave starting maybe but it's too
early to say because once again as you
can see as i'm right now using a daily
timeframe and whenever you use a daily
time frame you need today to be finished
to make an analysis on the candle you
see so maybe this candle is gonna it's
gonna be green at the end of the day
maybe it's gonna be red uh depending on
what we have we're gonna uh make some
assumption so amc is going to 26 right
now
okay so i'm probably going to get
executed soon which is good news
bam
uh okay
then i want to go on a shorter timeframe
guys to make with you some analysis
i like to see this negative beta first i
just said the negative beta is good news
for me because here i think that triple
q will drop so
if triple q drops
maybe it's going to be good for emc and
jimmy let's see yesterday it was a bit
like that the negative beta is not
happening all day but it's we can see it
happening during the day uh once again
this reminds me the good days this
negative beta so i'm happy to see it at
play
uh bam bam bam let's go in the shorter
time frame
uh
maybe we can discuss targets on gme
first okay
so let's discuss let's do that together
guys and give me some likes guys i can
see you are
more than yesterday so i think you enjoy
what is happening but it's pretty
obvious because given the strong moves
we're having i think everybody is happy
so
bam bam bam
jimmy targets
you guys know the target the target is
not very different from what it was last
year guys
but let's check that again
let's check that again
okay
so
bam
i'm gonna use a log scale just to have a
better
view of what is happening
okay
so it's pretty obvious what we need to
do guys we have this massive massive
move up here
uh and here this
massive pullback
but this press action is not very
i mean
um
unusual to me
we corrected quite deep
when i measured this whole move up
we corrected below this
78 78.6
fib ratio so of course
uh this is a deep correction that
happened we know that because you know
we weren't there
it was a long time i think that those
days are gone hopefully
so bam i measure the first move and i
applied to the bottom of
you know what i'm having here and guys
you know what we're looking at we know
what we are
um targeting here
and the target is unchanged guys okay so
we can of course discuss about the uh
kind of
normal levels but here the normal levels
are not working the 0.618 is a usual
projection ratio that we can use but
it's below the high okay so 380. so it's
not even
feasible then the very
i would say
um
conservative target is 570. okay but we
got we all know what's going to happen
if
we go to this level 570 this is gonna be
a blood bath for shorts so of course we
will probably go higher the reason why
it's going to be a blood bath for them
is that the recent high is 460 and i'm
very sure that there are a lot of shorts
that have this kind of
rules that you know they gave to the
manager or whoever they want
that is controlling what they do um they
probably said if we make a new high i
will reduce a little bit my position
something like that you know just to um
to give some um
security i would say to the firm they're
working for uh so
i'm
very convinced that above 460 if we can
go there once again i'm giving you
targets guys but you know that trading
is uh just i mean technical analysis is
just um trying to use some probabilities
associated with some scenarios so of
course there is nothing true but just
something that we've seen in the past
and that can happen again
uh so bam bam bam
and the usual target to do 1.618 guys i
don't know if you see well it has moved
a little bit okay uh
it was 800 last year
this show is 870. okay
so we use a little bit of different
method we have a different i mean we use
the same method but we have uh some
updates in the price action now the
price action went to the 878 level
uh so
870 is my squeeze target and on amc it
is 130 okay so i'm gonna add that
in my spreadsheet that i monitor
because as you guys know i'm monitoring
the spread that is trading between amc
and gme
and
bam
i'm checking the spread as you guys know
jimmy was trading
with the 20 premium last week the reason
behind was i think uh the massive option
expiry we had on march 25th
after this expiry happened we saw that
the spread has tightened and yesterday
amc catch up catch up on gme today
bam
-1 okay so the spread is gone all right
guys so right now we are having gme and
amc training at fair levels okay so
that's the first thing
and now as you can see those levels just
come from the stable i'm having here so
i think you don't see anything so i
would just be quick but i will add the
target 860
127 okay
and
it makes sense i have a ratio that is
always around between 5.5 and 6.8 okay
so whenever
i know amc price i know what is the
third gme price because once again i
think that uh with everything that
happened last year given the um
rational behind those two stocks uh
those ratios will be respected so
whenever we see that one of them is
lagging this is the one to buy okay
and for now no one is lagging
they are training at fair levels we're
gonna monitor that but you can do it
yourself you just use a six
six ratio basically okay so amc should
be six times more expensive than
jim
okay
so i see you have a lot of questions
guys i will try to answer all of them
but first
bam let's go quickly on a shorter
timeframe and let's see what happened
here guys
it's important to know
if there was volume or not in those
moves
it's important to see as well what is
happening with the momentum
okay so let's go step by step we were on
the daily timeframe let's go to hourly
timeframe
okay so on the hourly timeframe what do
we see we see a macd
that is
making a new high okay
so on the hourly timeframe we have the
mark the price action making your eyes
uh the macd making new highs the rsi
overbought quickly coming back to the 50
area and making new highs as well so we
don't have any thing that is bearish
here
in terms of volume we have the volume
steady
and massive okay so nothing uh bearish
here as well
so whenever you use the one hour time
frame
at the i mean the uh reasoning we can
make apply for the coming for the next
uh i would say three days roughly okay
so nothing very bearish on the next
three days which means that
maybe we're gonna have a little pullback
but
we're gonna stay bullish just looking at
this information
then i zoom in okay and so now the
information i'm gonna give is gonna
apply let's sound the next 24 hours 36
hours i'm on a 30 minutes time frame
okay
so
here from here to here the momentum is
still increasing
the rsi stable the volumes growing
but we have for the first time guys a
massive red
bar
that traded okay it's the first time it
happened so what is this telling us
um
by the way was i executed
oh
okay i wasn't done here
okay
uh
yeah so what is this telling us it's
just telling us that
some bulls lost money here so then we
can check if the move was big or not
it's quite big
okay so this is the first setback of the
bulls all right they got rejected here
quite brutally you know it's like
they took a slap in the face i would say
a little bit but
the bullish momentum is very strong so
they're probably gonna get back at it
this is what i said at the beginning
when we got rejected here i said we're
gonna come back to 26 and come back
uh we didn't reach 26 which is a shame
because i had some shares here
but
i mean i'm still happy to see nmc
growing going higher uh so
for now
i think that we are entering
a
volatile
day
uh
i would say that bulls for now lost
control on the very short term all right
because of this big red bar that i'm
seeing
but they still have
the momentum with them on the higher
time frame but if i zoom in a little bit
more
what do i see
okay so now
we see here some bearish signals
but almost 50 minutes time frame so it's
not going to be
so what i'm going to say is now applying
for the next eight hours so let's say
one training day we can see the market
making higher highs okay so i'm removing
that so we can see first that's the
analysis i've just done on the next
three days is
bullish all right at least not bearish
okay now i'm making the same analysis
that's gonna apply only for the next day
so
uh bam we can see market making high
highs okay
but so volume making higher highs here
with the green day and then of course
this uh big red bar which is not good we
have increasing volume but with a strong
rejection that happened at the end so we
don't like to see this rejection that is
forming kind of a shooting star
uh it's not a bullish pattern
it's not
bearish as well i mean it's it's
supposed to be bearish if it happens uh
really at the end of the uptrend and if
it's the candle should be a little bit
higher so i mean it's a little bit a
bearish pattern
uh on the 15 minute time frame once
again so what i'm saying is applying
only for the next day
and we can see the
rsi making lower lows
okay and the macd is it's unclear the
macd was making higher highs
okay sorry it's a lower highs i said
lower lows it's lower highs for the rsi
and now it's a bit uh you know shifting
so we can see we have a shift of
momentum that just happened
um today
on the 15 minute time frame
we reached the 32 33 level which was
a
level of
resistance for the reasons we've seen
before
so we can
hear
assume
that um
bulls for now lost control on the very
short term and i mean
we can see we are dropping five percent
today so it's very it's a very small
pullback compared to the massive move we
did yesterday but we can see that today
for now okay bulls started strong they
got rejected uh and the question is
where are they located so
uh we've seen already that 26 is our
first support
let's try to see because it's
interesting can we go lower than that of
course we can but
i mean is there any
um
i would say logical scenario where we go
lower than that i don't think so
i don't i don't think that 26 can really
break right now
okay
the next ratios are 23 and 21 so
i mean
the very very
um
i mean bearish
scenario
is that 26 is not holding and that we
need to find support a little bit lower
that we have a second wave pullback that
is a bit stronger and that we come back
to 21. i'm just giving you the scenario
guys because this would still be bullish
all right
uh given the strong
very strong impulse we had
uh it's almost impossible that bears
just take back control this is not a
scenario that makes sense
maybe
they will take back control eventually i
don't think so but
there's still gonna be a really big
fight happening at lower supports
because as you guys feel bulls are
just very excited and um
and very strong
so even if we drop
this levels would be very strong levels
for uh
for a bounce
so let's see for now my preferred
scenario is that
uh
we just go to 26 so as you can see this
first wave might be complete
we don't need to have like i said at the
beginning of the video a pullback that
is lasting more than you know one or two
days it can be a very
quick and shallow pullback here we uh
pulled back to the 38.2 percent which is
considered as a valid putback so maybe
this is our second wave uh maybe the
second wave is complete but um i i doubt
the second wave would last only one hour
okay when did we happen one hour
15 minutes ago the second wave needs to
last at least guys you know a good rule
of thumb is to consider
that corrective waves last around one
third of the motif wave so here the
motif the motif wave started
uh 14th of march all right and and today
is the 30s all right so two weeks uh two
weeks all right so divided by three so
it's like three trading days so
maybe two but i doubt
we get only one corrective candle we
need to have at least two given the move
up we have here
so it means that if the first wave is
complete maybe it's not complete maybe
today we're gonna close at 45 all right
that's very possible then we're just
going to adjust
uh our
you know fib ratios and we're gonna then
have 32 as
um
32 as the 38.2 uh
fib ratio and this would be then the
level where we probably only have two or
three candles okay maybe four if it
lasts if the first move up lasts a
little bit longer
for now we are like that okay so we can
keep this because this is for now what
is making the most sense
uh so i don't know it's looking like
maybe we're gonna consolidate between 26
and 33 for the next two days uh and then
we're gonna need to see once again what
is happening on shorter time frames for
now on shorter time frames like you have
seen we have some little bearish signals
uh
appearing for the next day maybe two
days so this would make sense with with
our second wave pullback that is right
now maybe taking place
um
i would like the second wave to last a
little bit longer because we need the
volatility to drop uh the volatility was
training at 150 yesterday
all right i'm taking the airport
25
strike so let's see today
okay
220 okay so the volatility is crazy high
so uh which makes sense because the
realized volatility is at 120. so you
can see this is very over uh priced
definitely
um
so we need at least
one or two
ideally three days of a calm
uh which which means that amc is not
moving up or down more than 10
which is considered as a quiet day now
uh for this volatility to come back and
once it's coming back the call options
are gonna be much much cheaper
okay guys so i'm gonna do the same thing
with jimmy we're gonna analyze what is
happening on the shorter time frame
just give me a sec
okay
then i'm going to check the other stocks
you guys are asking me
but pam pam pam
i will have a look at the chat later
guys but i'm very happy to see all of
your messages hey scott what's up bro
casey brother happy to see you again
okay guys so
bam
let's go on
gme show to timeframe let's analyze a
little bit what is happening here guys
so i'm here on a weekly timeframe guys
because this is what i use to give you
targets
so now i'm going back to the daily and
i'm gonna zoom in a little bit
so here what do we have we have
the first move we don't know if it's
complete or not like i said maybe the
first wave is going to go to 250.
uh
if this is the case amc should be
trading at 250 divided by 6 so
41.5 42 so it's in line with the 44
target we have here so i think that if
gm starts to go to 250 amc should go to
44. uh we've seen that on emc we had
some a little bearish signs starting on
the
30 15 minutes time frame so i'm going to
do the same thing on gme so for now on
the daily timeframe guys the macd is not
even starting to decrease it's still
almost accelerating on the upside given
the strong move earlier today
so we have a increasing momentum
uh volume
okay this i don't like to see that
it's not bearish but it's just not very
bullish okay whenever you see a strong
move that happened with increasing
volume
and then you don't pull back
and you have another strong move that
happens with lower volume which is not
the case on amc guys on amc the volume
was bigger the next day so this is very
bullish
on gme the volume was lower so what does
it tell us it tells us that you know you
just have less buyers
uh okay
so we prefer to see this volume just
growing okay we don't like to see the
volume starting to decrease especially
we know that we have a lot of room yes
look at that
25 million shares exchanged on the
biggest trading day
in jan we had
10 times more than that so we have a lot
of room for um
other players to join
the party so first thing
so here i'm having a little sign of
weakness
that happened yesterday and today we are
for now correcting a little bit
nothing very big but okay now i'm
zooming in for this timeframe
so my rsi going up
macd going up volume
big and stable okay on the first time
frame i don't see this decrease in
volume all right so the first time frame
is bullish
uh
support at 180 in terms of moving
average we have
okay let's try to see
we don't have anything very strong on
the first time frame in terms of moving
average 180
support okay
i'm sorry
160 sorry 180 was support this morning
it has been broken on quite decent
volume the next support is 160 has it
has it been touched
163 was touched we didn't touch 160 we
can expect maybe to have a reaction at
this level maybe during the day let's
see
if we do it's a good i think level to
buy once again not financial advice but
because um the followers momentum is
still increasing and i don't have any um
bearish signs here then i'm going to
audit i'm from
i would return frame
rsi starts to make lower lows compared
between here and here but it's still
quite stable volume rather growing but
once again we have this big red bar here
which we don't like to see we did we
didn't have this kind of um
information yesterday
so today we start to have the first sign
of weakness that maybe is telling us but
it's once again a weakness that i see
only if i zoom in a lot and maybe this
weakness is going to disappear by the
end of the day
um but it's a weakness that just applies
for the next 24 hours 48 hours all right
so it's
very in line with the second wave
pullback that we can expect that maybe
is happening right now it seems to me
this is
the secondary fullback is happening now
and
uh we can try to see how low it can go
but once again 160 is i think a
reasonable level
so to know how low it can go let's
assume we don't make any new high
i don't know if we do i'm gonna adjust
that
all right and i just measured the first
move up and the fib ratio is at 150
so um
you know i like to have a few ratio that
is in line with some of my trend lines i
don't have any at 150
so my take is that either we go only 260
which is gonna be gonna be very strong
or we go 200 and
okay here i can adjust this one i have
something at 147.
i can adjust that
okay 150 is actually a level that could
make sense because it's the recent high
we had here and it's the opening uh the
open we had here yesterday
so i don't know i don't see very clearly
it's an area like i said so the 150 area
is an area where potentially we could go
uh for this second wave pullback okay so
here for now i'm just gonna put this one
here once again why do i consider that
maybe this is um complete just because i
have five moves up which tells me that
maybe uh bulls had enough of it
then we can of course have an extension
an extended fifth wave all right so
we're gonna monitor that but for if you
have to be extended
we
we need to have more strength so
i right now doubt we can go to 250 right
now today um what could happen though is
that we make a new high on decreasing
momentum which is
a sign of exhaustion of this first move
up so it's possible you know to have
some kind of a wedge a little bit like
we had yesterday but yesterday which has
been broken on the upside and since then
it acted as support you can see we were
having this kind of weakness yesterday
um
and bulls got the best of it here
uh
above 160. right now we can
we could have the same kind of uh
pattern forming
uh with
the market making high highs but on
lower momentum let's see if we have that
it just means that the fifth wave is
about to uh give us a second wave
pullback that usually would be bought
okay
so for now this is the information we're
having
okay guys so uh what else can we have a
look at
i'm gonna go through the questions
you're having very soon
we can have a look
at
we can have a look
at
my watch list
uh then i'm gonna go through questions
but i'm very sure that somehow we can
have a look at hymc we bought some hymc
shares today at the open hundred and at
167 i think
uh so once again i know you guys
probably know already what is hymc it's
a gold and a silver mining company
that has been
targeted by amc
and um sprut i think another company
they both bought 22
uh
of the available shares of this company
then there was a share emission
so a delusion uh the short interest was
30 percent it was then seven percent we
need to see how it's going to be
adjusted but basically this is a very
short company very short company
okay
and i told you guys that uh the breakout
level was at so we bought here
uh i told you guys that the breakout
level was at 250.
so right now it's very interesting
because we happened quite
higher at
2.95
we got sold rejected okay fair enough
uh
if i see a close above the 250 level
today i'm gonna consider this
not as a very good breakout because for
breakout to be good quality you guys
know if you're following my videos for
some time that you need to have this
consolidation before the breakout just
like we have here but this is a
consideration that happened i don't know
if you guys see well
but this consideration is a good pattern
but we don't like to have something like
that before the consolation okay
this is creating noise we don't like
that so that's why this breakout you
know it it would have been perfect if it
would if it would have been without that
we have that we take it into account and
we just say that this is not the
breakout level the bracket level is here
we had already two reactions before
which is confirming that this is where
we have uh resistance and this
resistance has been broken today let's
see if it has been broken with big
volume or not so one hour has traded
already i can check the hourly time
frame
same thing guys i don't like to see that
i don't like to see this a big
volume
happening on the red candle okay it's
just not bullish uh so i would prefer to
sit on the green candle of course
but let's see what the the day is not
finished uh if we are able of course
to uh close ideally we would like to see
a green candle guys it's very
uh it's a very good sign sent to market
players that uh if they trade during the
day they usually make money they need to
have this information so that they can
you know decide to jump in the trade
more easily
so yeah
let's see what's gonna happen here guys
uh but if we close above 250 it's still
bullish and if we close above the open
so above 2.95 it's very bullish okay so
let's say that between 250 and 295 we
are looking good above 295 were looking
very good below 250
it's a rejection it's not looking good
okay
so
uh then
i'm gonna go through the watch list guys
just to check with you if you have some
if we have some signals once again this
is the watchlist i'm using for my
discord um
and
you know i will not do that every day so
i hope my discord members forgive me
that
uh
if i share this with everybody but i
think it's interesting for you to see
how things are working how you know
traders are actually trying to i mean
every trader has its own technique but
at least what i like to do
i just uh take some levels
and whenever i am close to this levels
on the pullback on or on the breakout i
consider that i need to have a closer
look at what is happening and i'm gonna
have a closer look at what is happening
around um on the stocks where i have a
target uh an alert which i uh once again
create myself so here
uh pam pam pam
so yeah we we can have a look at mara
i'm gonna have a look at this one
because mara is close
to the 32 level
where is 32 here so we can have a look
at that
but as you can see i note i i put this
in the bearish category so i'm gonna
have a closer look but
i this means that when i put the 32
level i thought we're gonna get rejected
there so let's see we're gonna analyze
this
um
then bam this is not very interesting
moderna
not very interesting
i know fisell once again well i'm
keeping an eye on this one the level is
680 if we're able to close above that
we're gonna be bullish guys
uh
bbig 365.
okay
okay amd
is starting to get close it's the first
time i'm seeing this one
ab i put it on bearish as well okay i'm
gonna have a look later
okay tesla you can have a look at tesla
guys tesla is close to the resistance so
let's see how things are happening there
okay d wack 73 we're not there yet okay
i don't have many oh bbby
28 i noted
okay so i'm gonna have a look at uh
tesla bbby
and mara okay let me know if you guys
want to see something else and of course
if we see amc or gm starting to move
strongly we're gonna have a look at that
but first like i said so mara quickly
let me do an update on the bitcoin first
okay so bitcoin uh
moving higher
okay
the question is can we develop doing a
one two three four five or are we gonna
get rejected here
uh so as you can see we have some
positive signs appearing after 43 000
breakouts okay but this breakout
happened on low volume which means that
it can very well fake out okay just like
we had back in the time here yes okay in
june 21 we had the same kind of pattern
that was forming a triangle
we had a breakout and it faded because
it happened on low volume here we have
the same breakout that happens on same
low volumes so for now this is not a
strong bullish sign even if it's rather
looking good
then we took back the 46 level on sunday
with slightly increasing volume as you
can see but it's still low volume guys
so it's not
i mean any
strong victory uh like we had of course
on amc and gme with massive volume so
this is what we need to see for the
bullish momentum to be sustainable in
time okay for now we don't have it with
bitcoin
we are granting higher on low volume so
this is not extremely bullish even if
it's random bullish and bearish um we
went through 46 000. the next resistance
level is 48 000 and we got rejected here
uh once yesterday we got
just a little bit rejected and we are
getting back at it so i think that to go
through this level we would need volume
so we're gonna have the answer of the
question which is is bitcoin ready to
rally again to make a new very strong
bullish cycle my answer is for now we
don't know it's probably gonna happen uh
i mean within a few months okay i'm not
taking too much risk here but for now
this is only what i can say
um but i'm not saying we're not making a
new low before that for now i don't have
the confirmation that bulls are taking
back control on the long term to get
this confirmation i need to see a
resistance where we have a lot of bears
so
i need to see a lot of volume trading
through when we go through a resistance
level that is here maybe 48 000 but once
again if we go through that without
volume i will still be saying guys we
can very well uh drop and make new lows
if i see that we go through the 48 000
with volume what do i call volume i call
volume something bigger than what we had
during this
corrective pattern yes this is a
corrective pattern all right this is not
something where uh any camp is leading
and even in these corrective patterns we
had much higher volume than what we're
having during this breakout okay a
breakout is not a good breakout if you
don't have volume so it doesn't mean we
can go we cannot go higher it just means
that we cannot use the signal as a
long-term signal for bull market
or let's say a bull run to start again
on bitcoin so once again uh here
i'm looking for the volume and i'm
waiting as long as i don't have the
volume i think that we can see a
pullback and maybe even new lows all
right i know we are far from that but
for now we don't have any strong
information to use
to
say that uh the bitcoin
um bull run is starting again okay and
then the next resistance is 52 000. and
here once again same thing if we go
through it with volume i'm gonna finally
you know be uh very confident in the new
bull run that is starting and i'm gonna
use fibs to buy the pullbacks all right
as usual so depends how high we go we're
gonna use either 38.2 or 50 we're gonna
see we're not there yet okay so this is
the plan and for now i'm waiting we are
bulls are in control in the short term
but on the medium term we have no
information long term i would say both
are still in control
all right so
can't
okay so as you can see this is what i'm
monitoring for mara
so i'm monitoring the 32 level
that acted so i can adjust this channel
a little bit
that is acting right now as resistance
okay
we have this okay basically we
moved below this trend line that was
acting as support during the whole bull
run in 2021
and now it's acting as resistance so we
need to take it back we have the 200-day
moving average at 25
and we have this trend line that is
still active so basically we have a
whole area of resistance here
okay so we need to go through that with
volume same thing so it's going to go
together with bitcoin so as long as we
are below 35
i don't see any strong massive move
happening on mara once we go above 35
then we need to be looking for uh
pullbacks that will probably be quick
and to start to
build some bullish scenarios for now
we're not there yet
okay
all right guys so i'm gonna go back to
quickly amc and jamie
okay let me read quickly your questions
i don't have the time stamp but i guess
this was at the beginning
hmm
37 8 of week yeah why not even 44 why 27
i mean i don't have any strong
resistance at 37
but i think that we can go to
maybe 45 so end of week so you're saying
that yeah maybe i don't know it depends
we need to know
uh
we need to know if this second wave
fullback has really started or not for
now it's looking like it it has so once
the second wave fullback is complete we
can go much higher than 45 right but we
need to reload a little bit some energy
all right for now we have still an
oversold uh overbought rsi so the rsi
needs to come back before the third wave
starts we need to have an rsi that is
coming back to decent level all right so
maybe 50 60 for now it's at 74. so
another boat rsi is not usually on a
daily timeframe is not usually what we
see at the beginning of the third waves
all right the second wave role is to
cool off uh everything you know market
participants and to
uh create a
favorable environment for this third
wave to push higher
okay brandon good morning brother
good stuff
okay so brendan i think answered the
question the gme target is 860.
i love the volatility yeah i agree it's
pretty exciting
okay guys
these fib levels even useful considering
back in gen 21 the buy button was
removed
true
in jan but in jan
the buy button was removed i think uh
only on robin hood right
or everywhere
i think it was a question of limits uh
that
that created you know too much risk
on
you know basically buyers were leveraged
so that's why i think robin hood was not
allowed
to um
to give them the opportunity to buy
shares without them having the capital
uh required on their account okay
basically they were making trading too
easy
for um
for the accounts that didn't have enough
liquidity i think it was something like
that and they fixed that they fixed that
in feb or march and
and this is the reason why in the june
21
strong move up that was
a little bit of squeeze
uh i don't think we had this kind of
issues remind me if i forget something
but i think that in this strong move
that we had here uh everything was
working properly because this issue has
been addressed has been fixed
so i don't think we're gonna have this
issue again i think it's gonna be fine
to buy shares on the way up
uh
as long as we stay in i would say no
more levels i consider normal anything
that is below 130 if we go above that
anything can happen
so this 130 and 870 levels would they be
during normal training hours i don't
know i i don't know i think that once
again this market is manipulated so we
don't know what's going to happen um the
best thing like i said
even if i know that you guys don't want
to sell you want to buy and hold
but for those who want to take profit
somewhere the best thing is once we get
close to this levels
uh so maybe once we start to be at 70 on
amc you know because from 70 we can just
do plus 100 and go there
uh it's good to place some selling order
in gdc so that at least your orders are
placed and even if you cannot connect to
the platform your orders are here and if
there is a strong buyer
like a short that needs to cover he's
gonna go through all the selling orders
and you're gonna get executed then you
just need to pray for the session not to
be cancelled which
like we've seen happened on mikael uh
not longer than last week guys
so
bam bam bam
okay
look at the 10 ma so i guess sma on the
four hours okay
but okay that's interesting because
i indeed didn't
have this one so it's like so let's move
my 20 and transform it to a 10. so i
guess you're talking about
an sma
yeah it's good
it's very good well done because this is
just like using the 20 under 8 hours but
i don't have the 8 hours time frame here
so
indeed i didn't check this one and i
agree it's giving very good reactions
very well spotted good job brother
my friend maybe from france
i don't know jean
well done bro i agree it's a very good
support that you just found so it is
right now at 24. so let's see what's
going to happen
but it's a very good dynamic support
that can be used
uh
once again we need to be careful because
once we see those
small bearish signs appearing
those moving averages that were
supporting the price well sometimes are
uh are broken but
we're gonna
need to
pay attention to all of that for now we
are still looking good
i think around 26 and 25.2 should we
bounce yes
i think that 26 for now is the strongest
support that we have and once again you
can
uh so let me take back my 20.
okay you know what i'm gonna add the 10
all right so we're gonna keep a look at
that i think is interesting so
let me add one moving average more
okay
let's give it
a color that we can see easily
okay i'm gonna put it in
pink
okay i put it in green
okay so
let's keep it on the chart
if i go back on the first time frame i'm
gonna see it
bam bam bam let me remove the drawings
okay bb i can have a look at bb
of course
divo
thanks andrew quality info yes brother
thanks
okay
interesting question adam i have a
screenshot of the ask for amc at six
hundred thousand
can someone explain this
it happened when it was halted
ah okay i think it's just you know a
default number
that your broker is using i don't think
it's a real order placed at six hundred
thousand
otherwise there must be some more orders
placed before so i think you would have
seen the other ones i think it's just
your broker that is placing this number
whenever there is a hat
can amc cross 100 yes it can uh as we've
seen the lower target if we have a
squeeze which we don't have for now
uh would be 130 127 adjusted the new
target
okay and i'm still looking for this six
hundred thousand level
i don't think anyone else can see it
okay silhouette
say please
victor
okay guys so we're gonna have a look at
we're gonna have a look at uh bam bam
bam let's have a look at the short
interest guys at the option market we
didn't have a look at it yet today
okay
so we can already see it's growing to 75
million shares yesterday
today we have 90 million shares all
right so it's it has 19 million
equivalent shares on the option market
uh the synthetic short is growing as
well guys the maximum synthetic shot is
growing the dtc is decreasing because
the volume shedding is higher
so
let's compare this is slightly lower
but look at that guys this is
interesting and like i've said
okay let me add this one
like i said we need to pay attention to
what is happening on the option market
to know if uh it's getting hot or not
for shorts and here
uh i can see the synthetic short grew
from six percent to seven percent and
the maximum synthetic shot grew from 15
to point 17.5 percent once again we can
check what levels we had back in the
time when we almost squeezed i
only have the information of august uh
didn't record it before but i guess it
was around twenty five percent so we are
at seventeen percent so you can see we
still have some job to do some work
from buyers uh to you know on this
option market to make it really hard for
shorts for now
it's hot but you know
i don't think they're going to cover
their i mean you know they prefer to
wait they're probably going to cover
maybe in the second wave pullback or
or not because before back in the time
they didn't do that so i think they're
going to cover on the upside all right
this is what they're here for
um
so let's see
and the regular shot of course no
information for now
we're gonna have a look at what is
happening um
on the 30s of march data which is going
to be released
in
one week
something like that for now i'm using
the 15th of march data the short is 20.3
um so we can also have a look at this
145 strike that is um representing the
bullishness of amc
and we have more than 10 million shares
i remind you guys that back in the time
we have here 20 million shares okay so
we still at half of what it was
before
let's see where this is coming from
to see how long we're gonna keep that
strike
exposure that is once again scary for
market makers
and it's coming from the here
gen 23 i guess
july okay
okay mostly coming from july
okay so this is giving us good
information guys this is telling us that
uh
this is where
most investors
uh see this quiz happening i mean most
of them see them see it happening before
july so let's see guys we had once again
the same kind of information back in the
time for jan 22 and we had to move down
but here the situation is very different
because of the strong impulse that is
looking like the beginning of something
so bam what else
i can have a look at your stocks guys
quickly
and i'm of course amc coming back to
flat almost
so we're gonna have a look at all of
that
okay
sorry just to say guys i lost my chats
okay i'm back
oh right so let's have a look at the
other stocks
so bbig
chile
okay let's do children because i had
some questions in in my discord about
that yesterday
or maybe two days ago all right so let's
analyze what is happening here so tyree
is a famous stock that has done some
massive moves in the past
uh
okay and it's pretty interesting to see
that
the volume
we're having here is the biggest volume
ever traded on tillway okay so this is
the first information that is quite
bullish then we like to see if the
breakouts are good quality for breakout
to be good quality it's good to have a
consideration before it here we don't
have it but this isn't i mean this
environment is not the usual environment
where
uh
sorry i want to keep amc here so i'm
gonna
switch that
bam so in this situation having a
consolidation that is happening a little
bit later is i mean something we often
see as well so here as you can see we
have this breakout with increasing
volume above the seven level
uh we also closed above the eight
780 level that was the uh previous
resistance that is now support and the
price action is conciliating here quite
high so this is bullish to me
um volume is slightly decreasing but the
price action is just you know stopping
here
it's hard to say if we can really move
much higher let's check what kind of
news we had
if it's really news related to the
company
decriminalization vote
okay so um i think it's more about the
environment
of uh tillery
than uh really some news about you know
the earnings or something that really
tells us that they make more money uh so
let's see for now this is bullish next
resistance is to me
here
around 10.
we also have the 200-day moving average
that is coming here so this is going to
be an important level uh if we go
across that it would be looking very
good
for now i think that this is a nice
opportunity not financial advice but
i mean i don't have anything bad to say
here we are just making a little pose it
seems to me um
and
it's looking like the beginning of
something given the massive volume then
that we had here let me quickly check if
what is the uh short interest on tiller
synthetic shorts and
a regular shot
okay bam bam bam
okay
ddc at 2.7
okay
short around 19
we can see we have a lot of options on
the 10 strike so this strike can cause a
lot of issues for option market makers
so we can expect that if we get close to
it we can go through it oh
okay and the 10 strike
is actually the level of resistance so
it seems that if we get close to it
we're just going to go through that
so here
a good
i mean
a good scenario would be that we just
get closer to that get a little bit
rejected and then go right through it
and then the next resistance is 14. so
let's see if we're able to do that but
this is
um this is a potential scenario that
would make sense to me
okay amc guys back in the green
okay it would be good to close in the
green again today
but once again the second wave pullback
is nothing bad is actually good to see
uh the market taking a breath you know
uh especially in an environment where
booze are in control in the global
market it's
i mean really not um worrying to me
um even having one or two more days you
know
around the study to level ideally what
would we would like to see guys is a
consolidation that is lasting even one
week to really take energy and a little
bit like we had here guys here you saw
how much energy we took we moved up
strongly and then there were like seven
days
seven trading days so it's like 10 real
days
of pose okay so ideally i would like to
see that and this would bring us in on
the 10th of april and then tenths of
april going through this 33 level again
with increasing volume this would be the
perfect scenario for this third wave to
be very strong and
and to go to
those uh targets that we have mentioned
before which are 130
and even maybe higher
okay bbig let me have a look at bbig
guys amc is moving up again
that's looking great
okay bbig guys is still since um you
know starting to make those lives i'm
analyzing bbig every day we are stuck
here
which is good because this is exactly
the type of consolidation that we like
to see for the market to take back
energy so right now if we go through the
320 level uh i think we we can have a
nice move up that is happening okay
this is a pretty good situation to me
so let's see if we can make it happen
but here the type of orders that we can
set
is a stop limit order above 320 not
financial advice but whenever the price
goes through 320 325
it would very likely continue of course
it can be a fake out but after
consideration like that that is quite
you know good quality
usually whenever you have a breakout it
holds okay so here once again if you go
through to 320 it would probably be
followed by a move to the 360 area and
maybe even higher okay
okay can we have an extended first wave
for amc yes i discussed that this
morning uh if the first wave is extended
i mean
a fifth wave extension in the first wave
uh we can very well go to uh the 45
level which would be in line with jimmy
going to 250. so once again we need to
monitor those two together because if
one is going the other one will probably
go so for gme to me the signal that we
start to go to this level is if we trade
above 200 basically if we get out from
this uh wedge that is not very clear yet
but maybe we are in a wedge just like we
were uh yesterday so above 200 it would
look like we are ready to push higher
but for now and we need volume of course
to be here for now we can have a look
again at what is happening on the
shorter timeframe on gme and amc
so
you see some red bars it's the first
time we see that guys so to me it looks
like for now um
we are just taking a breath okay we are
taking a breath that is uh very welcome
once again it's not a big issue to me
um
we can very well see a breakout above
the 200 level but we would need to see a
big volume coming just like we had
yesterday when we went through this
wedge upper band
okay it was here guys and we had
bam here you can see the volume was
increasing
during the day okay so we would need to
see the same kind of things around 200
so right now the volume is quite low so
if we go through 200 and we see a volume
around you know here
uh so as big as the false
15 minutes training today this would be
a signal good enough to me to say that
going to 250
is
a very possible scenario for now we're
not there
okay guys so i'm gonna do one or two
more
so uh and then like i said guys i want
to do some updates um about
you know the usual videos that i was
doing because i think that for some of
you it's interesting as well so the live
is gonna be a little bit shorter today
so i'm gonna do
two more stocks that you're asking me so
who asked first
i can see mvis i can see
at
okay so i'm gonna do those three quickly
guys bam so
after first
oh interesting situation on out there
okay
we are monitoring that uh we are very
close to the strength line and we are
consolidating very well below the 260
level let me add that in my watch list
this is an interesting situation because
the consideration is very nice so if we
break out above 260 with volume on a
daily timeframe so we need to have a
close above 260 with increasing volume
uh this would be a good signal that
something is happening all right so i'm
gonna
keep that here
yeah above 260. okay so this is in my
watch list i'm gonna see that and i'm
gonna share that with my discord if i
see it bam then
okay bb yeah bb was asked already a few
times so let me do bb
bam bam bam
same thing i'm keeping an eye on this
one guys as you can see i'm having some
drawings here uh so consolidating just
below this blue trend line that is here
guys
okay
we are trying to break out today
so it's nice
do i have this one in my
watch list
okay i'm monitoring a breakout above the
eighth level
uh
bam bam bam is it the right level to
monitor yes okay so i'm keeping an eye
on this one if we close above eight
today with volume it's bullish okay for
now we are not there
okay
okay qs i can do qs because i was in
that trade before it's a company that is
creating batteries
for electrical vehicles they have a very
promising technology
so i think that this company can uh
really do great if the ev sector is
booming again right now we have a little
pose yeah i want you to do tesla we'll
do tesla very soon so qs guys bam
something is happening
oh
so i missed it i had my
okay so it just happened yesterday
that's why i didn't see it
uh okay yes so this is bullish
this is bullish we have here a breakout
above uh this trend line that was here
and right we are right now moving higher
we find some resistance at 20.
guess let me see if it was in my watch
list i'm a bit surprised
i didn't see the alerts
okay
yeah but the alert just happened today
because the moves happened yesterday
so um
so right now we are up seven percent
and we had the big volume all right this
is bullish and let's see where we can go
okay so what could happen here the thing
is that we arrive on the resistance it's
not a strong resistance but we arrive
here in a resistance so it's never good
to buy just below a resistance it's
better to buy just above that
so definitely if we see
a pullback to the 18 area it's a very
good buying opportunity i'm going to be
personally here buying
then if we go through the 20 level
buying
on the way up is visible buying on a
pullback around 20 is feasible as well
okay
so just to say guys
okay yes i'm having here some news from
gabrielle
that is sending me that indeed i don't
know if you guys saw that yesterday but
yeah everybody saw it
bam big slap in the face i pretty much
agree with what will smith uh has done
not sure would have done the same but
you know
uh i think that it's coming from a very
genuine um
feeling towards his wife so i personally
support him a lot in what he has done
and all right and chris rocks comedy
tour sells third accounting to ticket
wrestler tick peak so you see we're
living in a funny world right
uh you know
the bad guys are doing well and let's
see maybe will smith will get would be
uh we'll get his oscar taken back i hope
not i hope he will not have any issues
but thanks very much for sharing
gabrielle
this is the market news today
so let's go back to qs yeah i think that
if we go above 20 then we can pull back
to 20 and it's of course again a good
level to buy but yeah my view is here
bullish okay so let's see what's going
to happen
oh right guys
so mvis
last one
m v i s
okay
indeed
we have something good that is happening
okay we are breaking out above
i agree
uh the
580 level 480 level
definitely the volume is already bigger
than yesterday and the day has only
started so it's looking good to me the
major resistance level though is at
rather here okay i like trend lines but
have a little reaction so this trend
line is maybe not very strong
let's see it is indeed a good signal so
it looks like you know we have a lot of
things happening in different stocks
i'm trying to find the best trend line
here
we had a nice consolidation here let's
check quickly the bollinger bands when
whenever bollinger bands are tight it's
increasing the probability of a good
breakout here they were only getting
titan we had this move that is crossing
the bollinger upper band which is a good
information
but let's see i still have some
resistance around 550. so let's see what
can happen here but this is looking good
as well i agree
will smith should be charged with
assault maybe he will but
i don't know i support the guy i think
that what he did even if he was violent
we don't like violence
um he protected his wife so it's always
you know good maybe not the best way but
whatever it's not the purpose of this
video thank you very much for watching
guys thank you for being here don't
forget to hit that like button if you
have not already uh subscribe to the
channel if you have not already as well
um once again not sure i'm gonna be live
today uh tomorrow we're gonna see maybe
i'm gonna do those uh updates as i used
to do before because some of you are
asking um but i'm gonna be here with you
anyway to um to comment the price action
on amc gme and your favorite stocks so
stay close to show i see you guys